next question one more question from
Mary more dos do you have any guilty
pleasure songs that you secretly listen
to nothing secret you know I got I'm not
embarrassed about what I like but I
don't know like a [ __ ]
what's unexpected yeah something new
maybe I mean they'll be like the odd
Katy Perry song that I think is good yep
yeah yeah on the same he recently
discovered Whitney Houston very recently
she was amazing she was yeah but you
know what when you you know when you
grew up with punk or the music yeah
and when you and you hear Whitney
Houston in an elevator you in your mind
you don't go oh I gotta get this but
then as you get older you start
appreciating people that have the talent
of their vocal cords control I mean
Mariah Carey same deal yes same deal
right saying man
but the Adele too but before that before
in my 30 ism
I wouldn't know who anyone was cuz I
didn't appreciate that I appreciated
like bands but it's like it was that's
the mainstream and when you're growing
up and you're another any music
obviously like no I'm not yeah yeah yeah
that's my parents music you know what I
used to do is I would have bought back
when there was no um you know internet
whatever you had to buy CDs and I was
living in San Diego and I hid Sarah
McLachlan's surfacing underneath my bed
as a CD and then when all my roommates
left I would pull that and and then any
album as later in the when we go on road
trips I loved it he it's always a Sarah
McLachlan just a frenzy he plays like
songs in a row he cries what's her song
cuz I think I've bought that for my mom
because I feel because she had a song
that I thought was really really
beautiful and I wonder if it was ice
cream no it's uh
I'm a dia a dia is it a dia lyric er you
noticing it yeah don't pretend like you
don't know her inside I've never said a
[ __ ] at Sarah McLachlan song on
pressure zone you're pressuring me into
it yeah if you give me that lyrics if I
look at the lyrics yeah I mean I'll sing
it you know oh [ __ ] you don't thing I
can sing it dude I'll [ __ ] sing it
right now I don't give a [ __ ] you want a
check I'm gonna challenge you right now
all right so just say give me one second
year eighty eighty Sarah McLachlan Sarah
McLachlan lyrics there we go boom yeah I
do believe I failed you how do I do it I
think you for the time that you start it
yeah yeah yeah this bird so much I got
it
cuz we were born in a cent
believe me Adia we are still innocent
it's easy we all falter right did I not
hit a couple of the good notes waiting
to catch the hood
hello that's not it then no yeah okay we
tried sir I'm travelling yeah
[Music]